Machu Picchu, geheimnisvolle Stadt in den Anden, hat man hier einfach nur gewohnt oder Kontakt zu Ausserirdischen hergestellt. Die Inka, harmloses Bauernvolk oder todbringende Aliens. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru, lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru, das Land ist mir morgsegal. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru, das Land ist mir morgsegal.
Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru, das ganze Land ist eine Qual.
Alpakas zu töten ist wie Zwiebeln schneiden, man weint, wie man das tut.
Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru, das Land ist mir morgsegal. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru, das ganze Land ist eine Qual. Vielen Dank! Andreas, der Dritte. Ja, und als Dritter im Bunde hinter dem Komponistenpult den Stab schwingend heute mal Zehnton Obsidian, der uns dieses Intro geschenkt hat. Von oben herab hat er es uns gereicht. Zehn Ton Obsidian? Hat er alle Zehntöne benutzt? Das weiss ich nicht, das muss unsere musikwissenschaftliche Analyse noch ergeben, das Ganze geht ins Labor.
Immer wenn wir uns ein Intro schicken, dann geht das natürlich erstmal ins Labor, dann wird das analysiert, sind da nicht geklaute Akkordfolgen drin, wie ist das mit dem Text ergeben, die Metaphern sind.
Und erst wenn das durch diese sehr harte Prüfung durchgeht, dann wird das auch hier gespielt, deswegen dauert das oft zu lange.
Die Leute schicken uns ein Intro und denken, ja, ratzfatz, das kommt direkt rein, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das geht teilweise wirklich bis zu zwei bis drei Jahre ins Labor. Das muss auch wirklich abgeklopft werden. Auf Fiss und Dur muss das abgeklopft werden. Was ich gar nicht wusste, was es aber wohl gibt, ist für Aquarianer, die so ein Meerwasserquatum zu Hause haben und irgendein Problem haben. Irgendwie eine komische Alge oder keine Ahnung, alle Fische schwimmen auf dem Bauch. Nicht zu verwechseln mit Aquaristen, die ein Aquarium haben ohne Fische. Ohne Ahnung. Achso, die Aquarianer jedenfalls können dann Proben ihres Wassers bei irgendeinem Problem einschicken an so Heizeklabore. Oh, das ist ja auch geil, ja. Und dann kriegst du nach fünf Monaten, wenn das Becken bereits schon wieder dreimal gekippt ist, kriegst du nur so eine richtig detaillierte Auswertung mit so fünf Seiten, Dina-Vier-Seiten und dann ganz klein so Areal-8 gedruckt, was das alles für Chemikalien drin sind und sowas.
Ja, ja, na ja. Ich denke mir so, es tut mir so leid, diese Leute mit einem Master in Biochemie oder sowas, die da drin sitzen und dann einfach von so random Leuten aus Castro Brauxel, der für seinen, weil die Tochter findet Nemo toll fand, so ein Meerwasser-Aquarium für 60 Liter aufgestellte. Und dann kommen jeden Tag die kranken Fische. Vater, was ist falsch mit mir? Wie kannst du mich heilen? Amadeus, wir warten noch auf die Ergebnisse. Meine Flossen tun so weh. Ich weiss, das sagst du jeden Tag. Sie schmerzen jeden Tag. Ich weiss. Jeder Flossenschlag wird zur Qual. Amadeus, ich weiss. Ich kann nicht weiterhin aufschreiben, was du sagst. Rette mich. Die letzten Stunden eines Fisches klingt. Ich kann so nicht weiterleben. Aber man kann nicht sagen, wenn man sagt, nein, ich gucke jeden Tag im Briefkasten, aber er ist nicht da. Er ist nicht da. Und dann kommen die Ergebnisse. Matthias, ich kann dir endlich sagen, was mir falsch ist. Gott, endlich. Töte mich endlich. Was ist falsch mit mir? Die Natriumphosphatwerte waren leicht zu hoch. Dieses Natriumphosphat. Okay. ich habe. Okay. Wenn man Akzente und Dialekte so schlecht kann, dass sie keine Bevölkerungsgruppe widerspiegeln, ist es auch kein, keine Ahnung, cultural appropriation. Fuck, jetzt hätte ich genau das Richtige zu sagen, wenn es mir einfallen würde. Jetzt hätte ich genau. Das sage ich sehr häufig abends bei Partys. Das wäre so ein Moment gewesen, wo ich eigentlich jetzt eine gute Replik hätte. Und dann gehe ich und komme nie wieder ins Gespräch. Weil ich habe letztens darüber nachgedacht, ob es möglich ist, einen fiktiven deutschen Dialekt sich auszudenken. Also den man erkennt als deutsch, aber der schlicht so nicht existiert. Ist möglich, halt uns nicht. Doch, und ich habe letztens eine Art zu sprechen gefunden, die genau passt, die ah fuck, mir fällt es an. Mann, du musst mir sowas im Vorhinein zukommen lassen, Mensch, du kannst das doch nicht einfach so aufbringen. Aber das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich glaube, das geht natürlich. Man müsste halt jetzt wissen, worin unterscheiden sich denn zum Beispiel alle Akzente und Dialekte, die es schon gerade so gibt. Also das gerollte R zum Beispiel in Kombination mit Sächsisch. Und zwar, es ist tatsächlich eher ein grammatisches Merkmal eines Dialekts. Und zwar habe ich nachgedacht, dass es manche
Wörter noch in so einer merkwürdigen
substantivierten Verbform gibt.
Ja, zum Beispiel das Wort
Schreibe.
Das benutzt man sehr selten.
Genau, deine Lache,
deine Schreibe. Deine Denke, das finde ich so doof.
Deine Denke. Ich finde das so doof.
Ach, die ist toll, die müssen wir einstellen, die hat eine tolle Denke.
Ich hasse das und ich würde sofort sagen, so ich kündige.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig, wenn man nachdenkt, gibt es einige Worte, die so funktionieren, wie Sorge, also aus Sorge in Sorge oder sowas, aber Lache finde ich auch sehr, sehr gut, aber es gibt nicht für alles, also zum Beispiel man sagt Meinung, man sagt nicht meine, also was ist denn deine Meine zu dem Thema und da habe ich mir gedacht, deine Meine zu dem Thema, sag mir deine Meine, in einer Art und da dachte ich mir, das könnte doch eine Art fiktiver deutscher Dialekt sein, der immer manchmal so zu viele von dieser Art von substantivierter Verbform benutzt, ich weißiss nicht genau, wie man das bezeichnet, aber der da das zu viel sagt, einfach so. Der nicht sagt Lauf, sondern Laufe. Karasek, deine Trinke, da muss man sagen. Wir wissen, Bertolt Brecht ist bekannt für seine Trinke. Trinke. Und dann auch Wienerisch noch ein und alles all over the place. Ah, ich habe gehört, seine Limericks habe ich gehört. Seine Limericks. Kablan Braricek, der hat die beste Lese in ganz Ungarn. Und Thomas Mann hat damals noch gesagt, deine Trinke gefällt mir nicht. Und niemand weiss, wer wir jetzt gerade waren, weil wir nichts waren.
Aber da dachte ich mir, zum Glück ist mir das eingefallen,
da dachte ich mir, dass das Grammatikale, das wäre unerträglich gewesen,
da dachte ich mir, das wäre eine coole Möglichkeit,
auch wenn man so eine Alienrasse oder so, die die Sprache über so einen PDF gelernt hat oder so
und die halt denkt, so funktionieren alle Substantive,
dass man das immer von einem Verb ableitet, irgendwie die Höre oder die Laufe oder die Gehe oder sowas. Ja, wahrscheinlich, aber ich finde die Frage super, kann man sich noch einen Dialekt ausdenken oder gibt es schon alle und natürlich gibt es nicht alle, also warum auch, es ist ja so random, so Auswüchse der deutschen Sprache, jetzt sagen wir mal, es gibt 16 Bundesländer, sagen wir mal jetzt einfach mal für die Vereinfachung 16 grob verschiedene Sprachideen und sowas. Das sind ja nicht alle Sachen, alle Möglichkeiten, die es in der deutschen Sprache gibt. Oft sind ja Dinge auch Mischungen von zwei, wo man jetzt sagt, man macht so eine grammatikalische Idee, wie du jetzt hast, dann schmeißt du noch ein, wie so ein Mixer, schmeißt oben dann noch irgendwie so ein gerolltes R rein. Genau. Und dann sind die Es sehr lang.
Ja. Die Es sind sehr flach und lang.
Weil es gibt ja viele grammatische Sachen so,
irgendwie ganz klassisch,
in Bayern sagt man immer vor Eigennamen noch der.
Mich hat der Stefan angerufen.
Und das ist ganz, ganz markant,
weil viele dann sagen, nämlich hat Stefan angerufen.
Das ist ganz klare Trennung, das muss man sich abgewöhnen aktiv.
Ich finde das so süß. Das ist ja auch ganz stark. Mit dem Stefan, mit dem Florentin. Genau. Vergleich mal kurz mit, was es mit euch macht, was das wohligere Gefühl in euch auslöst. Jetzt mal ganz kurz, wischt mal alle Gefühle weg, die ihr gerade habt. Wir brauchen euch gerade als reine, leere Leinwand. Magde, Vakuum. Zieht euch emotional mal aus. Zieht euch mal aus. Was findet ihr gemütlicher? Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo mit Stefan und Florentin. Oder? Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo mit dem Stefan und dem Florentin. Du hast es jetzt auch gemütlicher ausgetragen, aber es war ein bisschen suggestiv. Aber mit dem Stefan und dem Florentin. Aber Aber ist die Frage, ob das nur für uns Südländer
so wirkt oder ob in Norddeutschen sagen ...
Ich bin Nordmann.
Du bist Nordmann.
Naja.
Hab ich gelernt, dass die Aldi
Nord-Süd-Mauer
genau quasi
zwischen den Städten, in denen ich bislang
gewohnt habe. Also Dortmund ist noch Aldi Nord
und hier in Köln ist es
schon Aldi Süd. Zwei Herzen schlagen
in deiner Brust. Zwei Herzen schlagen
so schwach. Zwei Registrierkassen
Vielen Dank. lange gewohnt habe. Also Dortmund ist noch Aldi Nord und hier in Köln ist es schon Aldi Süd. Zwei Herzen schlagen in deiner Brust. Zwei Herzen schlagen so schwach. Zwei Registrierkasten piepen in deiner Seele. Ja, aber so schwach und es ist mir so fast egal. Also so ganz schwach schlagen die beide. Finde ich aber spannend. Damit würde ich eine Biografie eröffnen auf jeden Fall. Zu sagen, ich wurde geboren, ich wurde ins Leben geworfen, direkt auf einer Linie. Nicht zwischen Ländern, sondern zwischen Ideen. Zwischen Aldi Nord und Aldi Süd. Zwei Ideen, die unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten. Und mein ganzes Leben fühlte ich mich weder in dem einen noch in dem anderen wirklich zu Hause. Man kriegt mich aus dem Aldi Nordgebiet, aber nicht das Aldi Nordgebiet aus mir. Aber Ich liebe es, ich höre ja auch gerade die Werner Herzog-Autobiografie, ein Traum. Von ihm selbst gesprochen? Von ihm selber gesprochen. Ich habe, glaube ich, um da ranzukommen, vier Audible-Abos abgeschlossen und bin jetzt pleite, weil ich es nicht gerafft habe, wie es funktioniert, aber es ist mir egal. Audible. Ich bin wahrscheinlich Audible. Achtung, Audible. O-R-D-A-B-L-E. Audible. Ja, kann man ordern. Audible. Aber wahrscheinlich gibt es so eine... Sehen die in ihrer Statistik die Werner Herzog-Fans, die keine Ahnung von Technik haben, er hat ja legendärerweise das erste Mal mit 18 telefoniert oder so. Also der ist ja selber so ein ganz technisch unaffiner Mensch gewesen und auch heute noch schaut er ganz wenig Filme, nur so vier Filme im Jahr oder so. Also der ist total abgeschieden und ich finde das so passend, dass wenn seine Fans versuchen, ein Hörbuch zu erstehen, die auch die halbe Seite kaufen, einfach um da hinzukommen
irgendwie und es überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Gehen wir so ins Controlling.
Sorry, wir haben hier
merkwürdige... Gucken Sie sich mal
diese Statistik an. Gucken Sie sich mal diesen Graphen an.
Sehen Sie diesen Hubbel, diesen riesigen Berg,
diesen spitzen Berg da hinten? Ja, warte mal, was wurde
da veröffentlicht?
Warte mal, das ist der...
Was wurde da veröffentlicht? Achtung, falsch geschrieben. Ah. Man kann es nicht faken, weil man denkt immer, ja, der hat sich doch gerade offensichtlich verschrieben. Aber wenn der andere versucht, das zu kaschieren, dann würde er selbstbewusst einfach nicht dieses
sondern er würde einfach in dem Mod bleiben.
Nö, ich schreibe, das ist ein sehr langer Name.
Moment mal, da kam die Autobiografie von Werner Herzog raus.
Nein.
Wir haben die Herzog-Fans.
Wir schauen kurz aus dem Fenster.
Oh nein, da stehen sie. Ein Autokorso. Da stehen sie mit ihren Jack-Wolfskin-Jacken, mit ihren Jack-Wolfskin-Jacken, ihren Decreasing-Hairlines. Oder sie haben gar nichts, weil der ist ja auch mal geflogen und hatte gar kein Gepäck dabei. Der ist einfach so am Flughafen aufgetaucht und hatte nichts dabei, Kein Rucksack, keine Tasche, gar nichts. Wurde er auch. Er wurde verhaftet und stundenlang befragt, weil niemand sich erklärt, weil das so auffällig war und er hatte nur eine Zahnbürste in seiner Hosentasche und sonst nichts. Also so sehen vielleicht auch die Werner Herzog-Fans aus, die dann vor dem Büro warten. Aber er ist absolut grossartig, absolut fantastisch. Deswegen bin ich gerade im Autobiografie-Modessorten. Aber ist so eine ... so macht er Filme, so erzählt er Geschichten. Schon ein bisschen. Ich bin es auch noch nicht komplett durch, aber auch allein der Anfang, der hat halt so viel geilen Scheiss erlebt. Ja, durch diese Art. Der kann es halt auch erzählen, der ist halt einfach immer all in, radikal, der macht alles mit ganzem Herzen und sagt, jetzt ist Schluss, jetzt ziehe ich in ein anderes Land. Und dann auch so Nebensätze, ja, dann musste ich nach Mexiko fliegen. Okay, gut. Kennen wir alle. Alles klar. Dieses Gefühl, sonntags noch eine Beefy und zum Kiosk oder zum Zatanke, dieses Gefühl, jetzt einfach mal nach Mexiko, ich muss jetzt nach Mexiko. Ja. Und Frau Freundin sagt, ja, okay. Und ich glaube, es liegt auch daran, weil ich habe mich auch gefragt, manche Leute zieht irgendwie dieses Random Shit oder erzählenswerte Sachen, fliegen denen so zu und ich glaube, das ist, Werner Herzog ist so ein spezieller Mensch, der genau diese Kerbe schlägt, weil er halt immer selbstbewusst auftritt mit dieser Art. Der weiss ja auch, dass es weird ist, glaube ich, nur mit einer Zahnbürste aufzutreten. Ja, aber er geht dann halt einfach all in. Weil es wäre schon wieder uncooler, wenn er noch einen Rucksack hätte. Nee, fantastisch, kann ich nur empfehlen. Und vielleicht steige ich jetzt wieder ein in die große Welt der Hörbücher. War ich ja lange Fan, dann habe ich aufgehört. Oh, dann sind wir gerade diametral gegenüber, weil ich habe jetzt angefangen, wieder zu lesen. Ihr könnt uns ja die nächsten Monate beobachten und daran selbst testen machen, welche Form besser ist. Ich habe jetzt wieder angefangen, ganz normal zu lesen, weil ich habe auch wieder angefangen, das literarische Quartett zu gucken. Ah, geil. Die Urhaltendfolgen, kann man alle bei YouTube sehen, total spannend, teilweise sprachlich nicht so gut gealtert, teilweise fantastisch. Und ich schreibe mir immer Sachen auf, die ich wieder häufiger sagen will, beziehungsweise überhaupt mal sagen will, weil die reden so toll, dass ich mir denke, oh, unsere Sprache geht vor die Hunde. Und zwar möchte ich sagen, häufiger, Nolens Wohlenz. Oh, N Was natürlich das allerbeste, Nolens-Wohlenz heisst wohl oder übel. Und dann kann man so sagen, ja, das ist eine Autobiografie und da schwingt natürlich Nolens-Wohlenz auch mit, wir sind Eigenlob oder was auch immer. Also ich finde es so toll, Nolens-Wohlenz sollte man häufiger sagen. Wohl oder übel wird jetzt gestrichen aus unserem Wortschatz, Nolens, Wohlens wird reingenommen. Weil wenn ihr es schafft, auch Hausaufgabe, Nolens, Wohlens unterzubringen, und jetzt finde ich, das Ziel sollte sein, dass ihr zwar vielleicht, ihr könnt so einen Blick ernten oder sowas, aber keine Rückfrage. Keine Rückfrage. Ihr müsst es so selbstbewusst platzieren, dass niemand sagt, Entschuldigung, was war es gerade, Herr Meierling? Nein. Der, der, ja. Naja, ich wollte halt ein paar so Wasserkübel aufstellen, damit man sich was nehmen kann. Ach so. Sonst muss man ja Nolens Wohlens in die Küche gehen und sich eine Flasche nehmen. Okay. Deswegen wollte ich es. Ich mag auch die Besetzung, die sich im Laufe der Zeit immer ändert. Das ist so wie die Sugar Babes oder Power Ranger oder so, dass dann immer einer rausgeht, dann gibt es das Streit und dann ist wieder ein neuer da. Es ist einfach fantastisch. Und Massereich Nitzel ist auch einfach der beste Moderator der Welt, der einfach sagt, so Sendung ist zu Ende, tschüss, werde ich der Vorhang fällt. Vorhang fällt alle Fragen auf. Fantastisch. Der ist fantastisch. Am Anfang ist einer nicht mehr dabei, weil er dann der Redenschreiber vom Bundespräsidenten wird. Ja, ganz merkwürdig. Ganz merkwürdig, dann hat er das Gefühl, dass das widerspricht sich ein bisschen und steht einander im Wege, wo ich mich vorangegestellt habe, warum, weil das Literatische Quartett ja wirklich nicht in einem engen Moderationsbuch folgt, sondern du kannst sagen, was du willst. Es ist eine tolle Serie und ich habe tatsächlich versucht, also da führen wir jetzt zwei Welten zusammen, einmal natürlich die Frage, Sachen irgendwo zur Analyse schicken, denn ich habe Identitätsdiebstahl getrieben, in Kundenfälschung im weitesten Sinne, denn ich wollte mich einloggen auf schulportal.de. Vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner Hintergrund dazu, weil es gerade auch passt. Ich gebe es kurz ein. Warte. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich erinnerst, aber wir waren in Leipzig. Leipzig. Leipzig, okay, saßen Backstage und haben dann natürlich die ganzen Stars betrachtet, die dort alle schon aufgetreten sind. Wir reihen uns dann natürlich ganz bescheiden in eine lange Reihe ein aus David Hasselhoff, Mando Diaw, Alice Cooper, und auch Christina Stürmer. Und ich habe mich diese Woche noch mal intensiv beschäftigt mit Ich lebe. Dem Werk von Christina Stürmer. Genau, und vielleicht passt das ja zu unserer literarischen Quartettfolge, dass wir da noch mal einsteigen können, denn dieses Lied ist wild. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch daran erinnert. Ich lebe, weil du mein Atem bist, bin müde, weil du mein Kissen bist, bin durstig, weil du mein Wasser bist, du bist für mich mein zweites Ich. Fantastisch, ganz merkwürdige Zeilen, ganz merkwürdige Lyrics haben wir teilweise. Bisher hin ist es, wie ich finde, das künstlerischste Werk deutscher Lyrik im 21. Jahrhundert. Ich bin hier schon skeptisch, weil normalerweise würde man das, glaube ich, andersrum formulieren, nämlich, wenn ich müde bin, dann bist du mein Kissen, wenn ich durstig bin, dann bist du mein Wasser. Aber Frau Stürmer schreibt, weil du das Wasser bist, bin ich durstig. Also das Bedürfnis entsteht überhaupt erst, weil du die Befriedigung bist. Nein, aber das ergibt doch keinen Sinn. Nein, Herr Will, was Sie hier unterschlagen, und wir haben uns schon ganz, ganz doll gestritten, Backstage in Leipzig, weil wir kurz diesen Song gehört haben und haben darüber gesprochen und wir werden das heute in aller Ausführlichkeit tun, keine Angst. Aber du missverstehst diese Lyrik, du denkst nämlich die ganze Zeit, ah, das würde man ja normalerweise anders machen, weil du da irgendwie zu poppig dran gehst und so. Christina Stürmer wagt sich aber hier in neue Gefilde vor. Ich erkenne hier ganz klar ihre Kritik an der Abhängigkeit. Sie ist abhängig von ihrem Crush, würde man ja heute sagen. So, und sie ist nur müde, weil er das Kissen ist. Sie ist sozusagen abhängig von seinem Wesen, sie passt sich so an, chameleonartig. Ich verstehe schon, man würde es umgedreht machen, das ist die gelernte Variante, nicht das, was Christina Schirmer sagen will. Wir gucken mal weiter. Also der Satz, der mich glaube ich am meisten verwirrt hat, war, Achtung, jetzt kommen wir zu dem, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, Bridge oder irgendwie sowas, wo sie immer weitere Metaphern aufmacht, noch während der Zuhörer, der sich noch denkt, was war das gerade mit dem Wasser, singt sie weiter mit Du bist das Gift, doch das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich. Stopp, hier kurz. Wir machen kurz die Soundsysteme aus. Du bist das Gift, doch das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich. So, wir haben es hier mit Person A zu tun. Person A ist Gift, okay?
Ja, der Lover. Wir nennen ihn mal Paule. Wir nennen ihn Loverboy Paule. Ja. Person B Christina, das lyrische Ich. Der auktoriale Erzähler. Das wissen wir doch nicht. Wissen wir nicht. Ist in dem Fall das Gegengift. Nee. Doch. Nee. Ist die vergiftete Person. Ja genau, du bist das Gift. Also impliziert, ich bin vergiftet. Aber das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich. Genau. Du, ich bin so abhängig, wieder, das siehst du ja nicht. Auf diesem Auge bist du blind. Auf diesem Auge bist du blind, Herr Karasek. Nee, also ich muss sagen, das macht schon Sinn. Ich finde es jetzt auch nicht so toll formuliert und in gewisser Weise soll es ja auch nicht die Idee sein von Musik und Songtext, dass man dann irgendwann so mit gerunzelter Stirn vor der Boombox sitzt. Aber angenommen, du bist ... jemand ist das Gift, und unabhängig davon, ob ich es vergiftet bin oder nicht, diesen Vorklap brauche ich, diesen Präfix brauche ich gar nicht, aber das Gegengift dagegen würde gegen mich wirken, weil ich das Gift brauche.
Aber also meint sie sozusagen, ich bin vergiftet mit der Liebe zu dem Menschen, Paule. Jetzt gehe ich zum Arzt und der Arzt verschreibt mir ein Gegengift, das tötet das Gift, aber dadurch, dass das Gift abgestötet wird, wirkt es auch gegen mich, also wirkt es über den Umweg gegen mich oder bin ich so gleich. Denkst du mir zu wissenschaftlich? Ich will das genau wissen, weil sagt sie, ich bin genau wie du, weil du bist Gift, ich bin auch so ähnlich wie Gift, dass Gegengift gegen mich wirkt, weil Gegengift wirkt gegen Gift. Also Frage, du denkst mir das so biologisch irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt von einer speziellen Schlangenart gebissen werde und dann das Gegengift bekomme, heilt mich das. Wenn ich das Gegengift bekomme, ohne von dieser Schlange vorher, vielleicht ist es ja auch einfach ein Gift, was ich bekomme, weißt du? Aber sie ist doch vergiftet, das ist doch impliziert. Wenn sie sagt, du bist das Gift ... Nein, nein, das kommt alles von dir. Moment, du sagst ... A priori ... Moment, du sagst, Frau Stürmer ist nicht vergiftet, wenn sie ihrem Lover sagt, du bist das Gift? Jetzt müssen wir Nolands wohl noch mal genauer hinschauen. Weil ich bin nämlich der Meinung, dass ... Guck mal, wirklich mal, du bist von der schwarzen Viper, peruanischen Natter gebissen. Gut. So, und dann. Wie sie damals im Dschungel auf ihrer Lesereise. Wie ich damals. Da bin ich nur mit einer Zahnbürste hingereitet. Da war eine große, große Zarrer am Flughafen. Nee, und dann kriegst du aber jetzt das Gegengift von dieser schwarzen peruanischen Viper. Stell dir heraus, du wurdest gar nie gebissen. Das war nur, das war nur, weiß ich nicht, dein Rucksack hat sich eingebissen in deinen Rücken. Ja. Diese Schnalle von deinem Rucksack hat sich nur verhakt und das sah nur aus. So, stirbst du dann, weil das Gegengift auch ein Gift ist? Moment mal, warum ist ein Gegengift auch ein Gift? Kann ja auch ein Gift sein. Gegengift hat auch eine Wirkung. Also sie sagt, du bist das Gift, ich bin aber nicht von dir vergiftet. Nein, nein, das will ich gar nicht sagen. Würde jemand versuchen, mich zu heilen mit einem Gegengift, würde mich das töten, weil ich bin gar nicht mit dir vergiftet. Nein, das will ich gar nicht sagen. Das ist überhaupt nicht der Aussage. Sie ist doch verliebt über alle Massen, deswegen muss sie vergiftet sein, wenn sie ihren Partner als du bist.
Ich will nur sagen, es ist scheißegal, ob sie vergiftet ist oder nicht. Das Gegengift wirkt gegen sie. Und dementsprechend braucht sie das Gift in ihrem Körper. Was heißt, sie braucht, sie kann nicht ohne Gift leben. Das ist ja die Ambivalenz, die wir hier sehen. Nein, vielleicht will sie. Sie leidet unter der Liebe, aber sie kann auch nicht ohne. Genau. Das glaube ich, deswegen Gift ist ja was Negatives.
Schon.
Aber ihr Heilungsversuch, das Gegengift, würde sich auch wieder gegen sie richten, weil sie ohne das Gift noch schlechter dran ist. Mit ihm ist gerade scheisse, warum auch immer, was hat er gemacht, wissen wir nicht. Ohne ihn ist aber auch scheisse, weil sie braucht die Nähe. Das ist eine Abhängigkeit, die sie hat, ob sie will oder nicht. Jetzt kann man natürlich implizieren, dass sie sich einigermaßen als vergiftet betitelt.
Das hätte ich noch nicht vergiftet, hundertprozentig.
Falls ihr dachtet, die Zeile war schwer, dann kommen wir jetzt wirklich zu einem richtig schweren Punkt. Denn wir hören weiter nach.
Du bist das Gift, doch das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich.
Du bist das Geld, ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht. Okay? Du bist das Geld. Nichts ist hier okay. Ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht. Gleiche, es ist in gewisser Weise die gleiche Mechanik, wie das Gift. Aber was soll das bedeuten? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein, nein. Also, er ist das Geld. Ja. Jetzt wäre eigentlich wieder alles schön, wenn er das Kissen ist und sie ist müde. Alles toll. Und jetzt ist er auch noch Geld. Und jetzt ist er Geld. Okay. Und wenn sie es ausgibt, hat sie das beste Leben. Nein, sie problematisiert die Beziehung zu ihm. Es ist eine leere Liebe. Sie könnte auch sagen, ich liebe dich, aber du liebst mich nicht zurück. Das Schöne an Geld ist, wenn man es ausgibt und es lohnt sich. Das ist jetzt Christina Stürmer-Lyrik, nicht Stefan-Lyrik. Aber es fühlt sich nach nichts an. Also Moment mal, du sagst, du bist das Geld vergiftetes Geld aber wenn du eine geliebte Person ansprichst und sagst, du bist Geld dann würdest du doch sowas sagen wie, ich schliesse dich in einen Tresor oder für nichts auf der Welt würde ich dich ausgeben das ist sehr romantisch, ich schliesse dich in meinen kleinen Tresor halt die Luft an, ich schließe dich kurz in meinen selbst das beste Aldi Nord Sonderangebot würde ich dich ausgeben. Das ist sehr romantisch. Ich schließe dich in meinen kleinen Tresor. Halt die Luft an, schließe dich kurz in meinen Tresor.
Selbst das beste Aldi-Nord-Sonderangebot würde
ich dich nicht ausgeben, weil
du mir so viel wert bist. Sie
sagt aber, nein, wenn du Geld bist,
dann gebe ich dich, also
sagt sie, ganz kurz, wenn sie
sagt, du bist Geld, ich gebe dich aus,
es lohnt sich nicht, heisst das, das Geld ist
wertlos geworden? Oder heisst
es, du bist Geld, aber es lohnt sich nicht, deswegen gebe ich dich weg, ich gebe dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht, mit dir zu leben, wenn du Geld wärst, würde ich dich sofort ausgeben? Oder was meint sie mit, es lohnt sich nicht, dass das Geld wertlos ist? Die Leseanleitung gibt sie ja vorher, wie diese Zeilen zu verstehen sind.
Und ich sag mal, die etwas kompliziertere Zeile jetzt für Sie in dem Moment kommt ja da vor mit dem Gegengift. Jetzt danach, die Leseanleitung ist ja klar, er ist XY, ich bin nicht der erwartbare Ausgang, sondern es ist nicht gut, denn unsere Beziehung ist nicht gut. Aber was ist denn der erwartbare Ausgang, wenn ich mit einem geliebten Person sage, du bist Geld?
Was erwartet man? Ausgang, sondern es ist nicht gut, denn unsere Beziehung ist nicht gut. Aber was ist denn der erwartbare Ausgang, wenn ich mit einem geliebten Person sage, du bist Geld?
Was erwartet man denn
dann jetzt als nächstes? Wenn ich dich
habe, brauche ich kein Geld, denn du bist
mein Geld, mit dir bin ich glücklich. Geld macht
glücklich. In dieser Welt leben
wir gerade mit Christina Stürmer. Aber man würde doch seinen Partner
nicht ausgeben. Wenn ich
sagen würde, wenn du Geld wärst,
dann würde ich verhungern müssen, weil ich für dich kein Essen kaufen will oder so. Also in dem Moment, in dem du sagst, du bist mein Geld, kann man es doch nicht mehr weggeben, weil dann würdest du ja sagen, wenn du mein Geld bist und ich kaufe mir von dir ein Stück Brot, dann ist das Brot mehr wert als du. Die Metapher, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu ... Sorry, wenn man das aufmacht, aber sie redet von Geld und Geld ausgeben. Und da bin ich jetzt natürlich, ökonomisch geschult, wie ich bin, natürlich auch auf die Makroökonomie angewiesen. Was genau meint sie damit? Denkt sie denn überhaupt an die Inflation, Christina? Hast du denn da überhaupt ein Auge drauf? Jedes Land, glaube ich, wird ich ein bisschen zu hyperkomplex gedacht. Ich glaube, sie sagt, er ist das Geld, es macht sie glücklich, aber macht sie nicht glücklich. Geld macht glücklich und das ist, glaube ich, die einfachste Ebene. Wir sind auf einer Ebene. Wir gucken nicht hoch und runter, wir gehen keine komplizierte Ruhe. Es lohnt sich nicht. Was meint sie damit? Ich werde nicht glücklich, das Geld auszugeben. Ich bin gerade nicht glücklich dabei, Geld auszugeben.
Ich gebe nicht aus. Ich finde, man kann es auf zwei Arten lesen. Man kann es entweder lesen, wenn du Geld wärst und ich würde dich ausgeben, dann wäre das kein gutes Geschäft, weil entweder, weil du so wenig wert bist oder weil das, was ich für dich kriege, nichts wie weil letztens... Aber jetzt fängst du mit so Wechselkursen an. Wie viel Euro ist ein Paule wert? Das ist mir zu schwierig, das ist mir zu kompliziert gedacht. Also die Frage ist, man kann ja natürlich auch eine gewisse Verachtung reininterpretieren, im Sinne von, du bist das Geld, aber es lohnt sich nicht mit dir, also gebe ich dich aus. ich geb dich weg, weil es so weh tut mit dir, weil du bist mein Gift.
Ich kann nicht ohne dir, ich kann nicht mit dir, deswegen würde ich dich,
aber wenn du Geld wärst, es lohnt sich nicht mit dir, ich gebe dich aus.
Aber wo kommt denn das plötzlich her, diese Stimmung gegen ihn?
Das ist doch schon angesprochen mit du bist das Gift.
Und mit Gegengift wird doch auch impliziert, dass sie geheilt wird von ihm.
Nein, das Gegengift wird gegen sie. Ja, aber wäre er kein Gift, wäre Gegengift überhaupt nicht im Spiel. Jetzt wird es mir zu polemisch und zu albern. Wenn die Autorin sagt, du bist Gift und dann Gegengift erwähnt, dann ist doch ein Heilungswunsch impliziert, dass sie von ihm geheilt werden möchte. Für sie nicht. Natürlich, deswegen ist doch Gegengift im Spiel. Ja, das Gegengift wird gegen sie. Ihr Heilungsversuch lesen. Ihr Heilungsversuch misslingt, aber der Wunsch ist da. Der Wunsch ist da, aber er würde sie töten. Genau, sie kann nicht mit ihm, sondern nicht ohne ihm. Und mit dem Geld, wenn sie sagt, du bist das Geld. Ach komm, sie. Und dann sagt sie, ich geb dich aus, weil es sich nicht lohnt, ich will dich loshaben. Geld ist zwar wertvoll, aber wenn du mein Geld wärst, dann würde ich dich ganz schnell ausgeben, weil ich will dich
loshaben. Aber das ist doch nicht, das ist doch
ein super, das ist doch völliger Unsinn. Wir reden
von Christoph Schirmer, das ist ja keine, du
redest ja super, also Geld loswerden,
was ist das für ein Unsinn? Ich geb dich aus,
es lohnt sich nicht. Aber ich geb dich aus,
Geld ausgeben, was kaufst du dich denn davon?
Da geht es ja darum, dass du dich ein schönes Leben machen willst.
In dieser Populierik, in der wir gerade sind.
Ich akzeptiere natürlich auch die andere, wo man sagt, ich geb dich aus, aber es lohnt sich nicht, weil du so wenig wert bist.
Nein, nein, nein, auch das ist völlig falsch interpretiert.
Warum denn?
Es lohnt sich nicht.
Ja, worauf bezieht sich das? Es lohnt sich nicht. Was lohnt sich nicht, Frau Stürmer?
Es bringt nichts, es bringt nichts, ich fühle dabei nichts, es lohnt sich nichts, es fühlt sich nichts an.
Das ist das gemeint, das ist gemeint, das bin ich sehrint. Wenn sie ihn ausgibt, dann fühlt sie dabei nichts. Du bist das Geld, ich gebe dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht. Es lohnt sich nicht. Es bringt nichts, ich fühle dabei nichts. Die Güter, die ich dafür bekomme, fühlen sich nachher nichts an, es lohnt sich nichts, ich merke dabei nichts. Also er ist wertloses Geld, er ist nicht viel wert. Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Aber das ist doch genau das, was du gesagt hast. Nee, ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo er weg ist, fühlt sich das nach nichts an. Also wenn er Geld ist, ist es für sie ein schlechter Deal, ihn abzugeben, weil das, was sie dafür bekommen würde, selbst wenn es ein Haus an der Côte d'Azur ist, wäre das für sie nichts wert, weil sie ihn ausgegeben hat. Ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich. Aha, also es ist doch wirklich echte Romantik, egal was ich mir für dich kaufe. Es ist die ganze Zeit echte Romantik, klar. Bei Du bist Gift ist es keine, es ist eine ambivalente Romantik, es ist eigentlich eher ein Schmerz. Achtung, kann ich Entschuldigung noch mal die allererste Liedzeile in Erinnerung rufen. Bitte, fahren Sie fort. Die nämlich, die da heißt, du bist die Qual. Ach, okay. Ich war schon immer Masochist. Hier haben wir es doch im Grunde. Ja, das ist doch die Lesanleitung. Da verstehe ich gar nicht, warum sie das mit Makroökonomie anfacht. Aber weiss eben, du bist die Qual, das ist doch keine reine Romantik. Im Sinne von, wenn du Geld wärst, würde ich dich niemals ausgeben, weil nichts auf der Welt so viel wert sein kann wie du. Nein, aber sie braucht ja Geld zum Leben. Das ist doch keine gebrochene Romantik. Sie braucht doch Geld zum Leben, sie muss doch Dinge ausgeben. Was ist denn für eine komische Lesart jetzt? Also sie muss ja, wenn er ihr Geld wäre, muss sie ihn ja loswerden. Sie muss sich ja Dinge besorgen, aber es lohnt sich nicht. Das ist ja auch eine Qual impliziert. Können wir uns vielleicht einfach darauf einigen, dass Geld eine sehr schwache Metapher ist? Voll. Bei einer Liebesbeziehung. Unglaublich schwach. Aber trotzdem muss man es ja richtig interpretieren, diese sehr, sehr schwache Lyrik. Aber wenn sie Dinge, ich meine, stell dir mal vor, wie schlimm das wäre, wenn die Geliebte Geld wäre gleichzeitig. Man gibt sie aus, weil man in die Runden kommen muss, ich brauche Wasser, ich brauche Lebensmittel, gib sie aus und verliere immer mehr von ihr. Es lohnt sich nicht, lieber behalten, aber dann stirbt sie auch, die Qual ist impliziert. Wir machen weiter mit, wie finde ich relativ simpel, du bist der Rausch und ich will noch mehr Alkohol. Relativ simpel, würde ich sagen. Aber lustigerweise dann doch wieder nicht so simpel, weil hier ist es eins zu eins lesbar. Genau, hier ist es eins zu eins. Hier gibt es keine Qual. Richtig. Rausch denkbar. Rausch ist nicht schlecht. Erstmal per se. Im Englischen Intoxication eher das Gift wieder implizit. Ja, im Deutschen nicht. Da ist natürlich auch der kulturelle Hintergrund anders. Na klar, ist eine ganz andere Hintergrund. Man guckt da anders drauf. Guck da anders drauf. So, und jetzt kommen wir zu dem ganz spannenden Punkt. Du bist die Welt, du bist die Welt, gut, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält. Hier unterläuft der Autorin der erste schwere grammatikalische Fehler.
Denn es heißt Du bist die Welt, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält.
Ich habe mich mit Schüren...
Die Schattenlicht.
Zwei Wörter.
Du bist die Welt, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält. So, und jetzt ist es aber interessant, weil ich möchte das gleich auflösen, wenn Christina-Stürmer-Fans vielleicht im Raume sind. Nee, ich gucke mich um und die ist kein Christina-Stürmer-Fan. Denn es gibt zwei Versionen von dieser Textstelle. Ich bin extra reingegangen, es gibt verschiedene Versionen von diesem Lied und ich habe mir alle angehört. Es gibt verschiedene Versionen mit verschiedenen Texten. Es gibt die Radio-Versionen, es gibt verschiedene Versionen und es gibt die Version, in der sie singt, du bist die Welt, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält und dann gibt es eine andere Version, wo sie singt, du bist die Welt, wo Schattenlicht gefangen hält. Meine Vermutung, Frau Stürmer hat sich versungen in einer Version und hat gesungen, du bist die Welt, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält. Diese Version ist so auf Spotify zu finden. Das ist eine offizielle Version des Songs, wo sie, glaube ich, falsch gesungen hat, du bist die Welt, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält, was schlicht keinen Sinn hat. Das ergibt gar keinen Sinn. Es muss heissen, du bist die Welt, wo Schattenlicht gefangen hält.
Aber guckt mal, es gibt Versionen, in der sie das, glaube ich, einfach falsch gesungen hat. Wenn du den Satz nicht zu Ende sprichst, klingt dieses wo immer schrecklich falsch. Ja, wir können ja mal reinkommen. Ich finde, das ist mit die schwächste Metapher, weil ... Hier verheiz ich mich spätestens auch.
Du bist die Welt, wo Schatten Licht gefangen hält. Ich würde mal sagen, er ist der Schatten und er hält sie gefangen. Oder die Liebe im Allgemeinen, wie sie sie zu ihm fühlt, ist ein Schatten, der sozusagen das Licht, ihre Liebe, gefangen hält. Es ist zu viel Schatten. Wir schreiben ja hier eigentlich eine toxische Beziehung.
Da ist eine echte Liebe da, aber sie ist umhüllt von so viel Schatten, dass es sich wie eine Gefangennahme anfühlt. Wir wissen nicht, das ist auch wieder schwach. Wir wissen ja gar nicht, was wird hier besprochen. Gibt es eine Abhängigkeit, weil sie in einer Beziehung stecken, die schlecht läuft, sie braucht ihn aber irgendwie? Also, keine Ahnung. Oder ist es ein Crush, der nicht erwidert wird? Genau, ganz spannende Frage. Sind die beiden überhaupt zusammen? Gibt es eine Beziehung
oder ist es eine unerwiderte Liebe?
Aber hier bleibt Stürmer auf der Oberfläche.
Hier wird nicht eingetaucht. Ja, macht sie es bewusst
ambivalent. Nein, hier wird mit schwachen
Metaphern versucht,
die eigene
Schwierigkeit, sich zu
entscheiden oder die Frage, was man hier überhaupt
erzählen will, zu vertuschen. Dann lieber doch eine
Metapher reinhauen, die an der Oberfläche
bleibt. Das ist schwach. Es ist auch eine schwache
Vielen Dank. ich sag mal, Schwierigkeit, sich zu entscheiden oder die Frage, was man hier überhaupt erzählen will, zu vertuschen, dann lieber doch eine Metapher reinhauen, die ursprünglich bleibt. Das ist schwach. Es ist auch eine schwache Metapher, weil Welten halten nichts gefangen. Also du bist die Welt, wo Schattenlicht gefangen hält. Ja, nein, das ist jetzt wieder unsinnig. Das finde ich unsinnig, weil natürlich Welt, Schatten, Licht, Tag, Nacht, okay, das hat was mit einer Welt zu tun, aber zu sagen, du bist die Welt. Du bist eine Welt. Also man kann einer Welt nahezu keine Eigenschaften zuschalten. Doch, eine Fantasywelt. Fantasywelt? Ja, das ist wie so, kann man auch sagen, in der Fantasywelt von Der Herr der Ringe passiert das und das, sind die Regeln so und so. Aber du kannst doch nicht die Metapher aufmachen, du bist die Welt, also du kannst sagen, du bist für mich alles, dann bist du eine Welt. Nein du kannst das doch nicht, also du bist eine Welt, nee, das finde ich, das finde ich auch nicht schön, ich finde es auch nicht schön, aber jetzt darauf rumzureiten, ich finde es nicht falsch, ich finde es nur unschön, aber ich glaube, da findet man andere Metaphern, finde ich auch, finde ich auch, als Welt, da kommen wir ja zusammen, so, und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie das ist, ich finde, es gibt schon Hinweise dafür, dass hier eine längere Beziehung vorliegt. Wenn ich das so höre, du bist Gift oder so, das ist alles langsam wirkend, das ist über längeren Zeitraum. Wir haben einmal hier die Bombe tickt, hast mich entführt, du Terrorist. Also eine Entführung ist ja für mich auch etwas, das jetzt schon länger andauert. Ganz kurz. Herzgestohlen ich habe das Herzgestohlen. Ja, genau, finde ich einen guten Unterschied. Ein Diebstahl ist ein einmaliger Moment. Eine Entführung ist ein andauernder Zustand. Du bist konstant entführt. Aber vielleicht waren sie noch nie richtig verliebt. Vielleicht waren sie noch nie so lange verliebt, dass der Crush ... Das können Sie gerne in meiner Autobiografie nachlesen, die jetzt bei Audible verfügbar ist, dass ich schon mindestens zweimal verliebt war in meinem Leben. Also das ist albern.
Und in der ersten Zeile hören wir auch noch, hast mich in Fürth Terrorist, schmeckst bittersüss, saugst mich aus wie ein Vampir, wo ich die gelbe Karte ziehen möchte, Frau Stürmer. Man kann nicht sagen, du schmeckst bittersüss, du saugst mich aus wie ein Vampir. Das geht nicht, weil in dem Moment sagst du, du schmeckst nach etwas und dann wird eine umgedrehte Richtung beschrieben. Das ist alles faul, das kommt nicht so. Eine Zeit, die mich auch nochmal stark verwirrt hat, ich glaube, damit können wir es abschliessen, und zwar haben wir jetzt in gewisser Weise den Höhepunkt des Liedes. Wir haben einmal diese Situation beschrieben und jetzt kommt aber sie, die ausbrechen möchte aus dieser festgefahrenen toxischen Beziehung, aus dieser Situation, die so unerträglich ist für sie. Und zwar fängt das an mit Ich stehe an der Front, gedankenleerer Horizont, du bist verliebt, wie schön für dich, warum sagst du es nie? Und jetzt wird es ein bisschen schwierig, weil ich dachte gerade, ich hätte es verstanden. Ich hätte diesen Koloss von Songs geknackt. Weil du hast ja gesagt, es geht um eine unerwiderte Liebe. Jetzt hören wir hier, du bist verliebt. Was ja eigentlich für sie das schönste ist,
was sie hören kann, wenn sie hört, ihr Partner ist verliebt. Sie reagiert aber zynisch mit
wie schön für dich.
Warum sagst du es nie?
Naja, also, jetzt habe ich gedacht
die ganze Zeit, ich habe jetzt an einen eigenen Crush gedacht.
Lange gehabt, lange nicht
gedacht, erwidert worden,
ich habe es aber auch nie nachgeprüft, es wurde aber auch nie was
gesagt. So, und jetzt dann kommt von ihr, du bist verliebt, ah, vielleicht gesteht ihr jetzt die Liebe. Jetzt nach Monaten des unentgegengebrachten, der unentgegengebrachten Liebe, der unerwiderten Liebe, in denen man natürlich in seinem Kopf so eine Hassliebe pflegt, mit diesem Crush, kommt plötzlich raus, ah, die Gefühle werden erwidert. Ja, wie schön für dich, also dann reagiert sie natürlich Christina stürmerhaft, flapsig, locker lustig, wie schön für dich, warum sagst du es denn nicht? Jetzt kann man sich auch einen Kuss vorstellen. Stopp, stopp, sie sagt aber eben nicht nicht, sie sagt, warum sagst du es nie? Was für mich eine längere Beziehung impliziert. Sie sind lange zusammen, aber er sagt zu ihr nie, dass er sie liebt. Warum sagst du es nie? Und jetzt ist aber die Frage dieses Du bist verliebt. Wo kommt das her? Also woher weiss sie das? Du bist verliebt? Wie schön für dich. Also in meinem Kopf, ich habe mir das ein bisschen zurechtgesponnen, ist, dass vielleicht ein Freund von ihm mit ihr redet und sagt, ach, der Paule, der ist so verliebt. Und dann sagt sie, wirklich, schön für dich, warum kommt davon nichts bei mir an, von deiner Liebe, warum sagst du es nie? Und da bin ich auch, dass sie in einer längeren Beziehung sind, weil sonst ergibt das nie keinen Sinn. Wenn man sich einmal getroffen hat, dann sagt man nicht, warum sagst du mir nie, dass du mich liebst. Ja, ja, ja, ja, unsinnig. Also ich finde es nicht clever, hier wird nicht tief genug eingestiegen und so und es bleibt halt auf dieser metaphorischen Oberfläche und löst sich nicht auf. Na, ich bräuchte einfach eine klare Hintergrundgeschichte, eine Personenkonstellation,fach mal, wo man sagt, was passiert, wie lange seid ihr zusammen?
Crossmedial könnte ihr vielleicht das Musikvideo helfen.
Könnte das Musikvideo helfen? Nein.
Glaub mir.
Das könnt ihr euch gerne als zusätzliche Hausaufgabe
zu Hause anschauen, aber es hilft
nicht, überhaupt nicht. Florian hat die Augen
ganz doll groß aufgemacht und
schüttelt mit dem Kopf. Weil das Musikvideo
spielt sehr auf diese eine Zeile an, die ich auch
sehr schwach finde, nämlich der Refrain Ich lebe, weil du mein Atem bist, bin müde und so weiter, endet ja mit, du bist für mich mein zweites Ich. Was ich auch nicht klar finde, weil sie beschreibt ja eine gerade nicht harmonische Beziehung mit jemandem, der Gift ist, der eine Qual ist, der ein Terrorist ist. Und jetzt zu sagen, du bist mein zweites Ich, he natürlich, also wenn du stirbst, sterbe ich auch. Also wir sind quasi gleich immer, also wir sind so zusammen. Was ist, wenn sie mit sich selber spricht? Was ist, wenn sie hier vor dem Spiegel steht und mit sich selber spricht? Sie sagt sich selber nie, dass sie sich liebt. Und jetzt kann ich nämlich angreifen. Jetzt habe ich nämlich ein Gefühl, jetzt habe ich einen Zugriff. Reiner. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, man hat mit sich selber ja auch eine ambivalente Beziehung. Ja. Man ist abhängig von sich, man braucht sich, aber manchmal mag man sich nicht. Manchmal kann man sich selber nicht in die Augen gucken. Man mag nicht, wie man spricht, man hört sich nicht gerne selber beim Reden zu. Und man sagt sich vielleicht auch nie, dass man sich mag. Dass man sich liebt. Geh mir damit doch mal nochmal zurück zu dem Gift. Du bist für mich mein zweites Ich. Zurück zu dem Gift. Wenn sie zu sich selbst sagt, du bist das Gift, also sie ist selber Gift, kann Gift überhaupt Gift vergiften? Da müssen die Botaniker jetzt mal Eintracht schreiten. Doch das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich, weil sie selber das Gift ist. Ja, diese Zeile ist aber in allen Variationen großer Unfug.
Und dann kommt der grosse Klimax, sie versucht auszubrechen aus dieser Situation, die ihr so viel Schmerz zufügt. Und zwar dreht sie jetzt den Refrain nochmal um in einem grossen Finale und sie schreit, komm lebe, weil ich dein Atem bin. Jetzt dreht sie es um, imperativ, komm lebe, weil ich dein Atem bin und jetzt mit einem imperativen, den es in der deutschen Sprache glaube ich so nie wiedergeben wird, sei müde, wenn ich dein Kissen bin, sei durstig. Liebe mich, schreit sie hier. Christian Stürmer ballt die Fäuste und sagt Liebe mich. Nein, was sie sagt ist, sei abhängig von mir.
Sie löst nämlich die Abhängigkeit nicht auf, wie man es vielleicht in einer gesunden Beziehung machen könnte, zu sagen, hey, wir sind zu abhängig voneinander. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie das Problem hat, die wird im Refrain. Im Refrain weiß ich nicht, ob sie das Problem hat. Es ist, glaube ich, fast eine Verzweifelte. Sie kennt vielleicht gar keine andere Liebe als diese schmerzhafte Abhängigkeit. Das heisst, die einzige Art für sie auszudrücken, dass er sie lieben soll, ist, was ja absolut paradox ist, sei müde, sei durstig. Also sie versucht jetzt die Bedürfnisse, die sie für ihn hat, bei ihm einzupflanzen, die nur sie heilen kann. Sie fordert seine Liebe ein, sie fordert aber auch ihre Probleme mit der Liebe zu ihm, von ihm ein, mit ihr zu haben. Sie sagt, sei müde, wenn ich dein Kissen bin. Also auch nur ich darf die Bedürfnisse befriedigen, die du hast. Also auch hier ist das ein, finde ich, schon angelegt, dass es hier zu weiteren Katastrophen wird. Also von einer offenen Beziehung hat sie noch nie gehört, kann man ja auch sagen. Nein, es ist natürlich ein, finde ich, verzweifeltes Ende, ein tragisches Ende, weil sie nicht weiss, wie sie mit der Liebe umgehen sollen. Sie kennt eben nur diese tödliche, schmerzhafte Liebe, die sie jetzt auch von ihm einfordert. Und wir alle ahnen, dass das nicht gut ausgeht. Löst der Song sich harmonisch hinten auf oder bleibt er offen? Das weiss ich nicht. Und jetzt, nach all diesem Hin und Her, dachte ich mir natürlich, was sagen die Experten? Was sagen die Experten? Und ich habe geguckt, ob es Interpretationen zu diesem Lied gibt. Und es gibt ein paar Interpretationen von Hobby-Pop-Textanalysanten, Analytikern, nichts Spektakuläres, ich habe es mir durchgelesen, aber, und jetzt komme ich zu dem, worum es eigentlich geht, es gibt einige Schulaufgaben zu diesem Lied, nämlich Deutschklasse und vor allem auch als Klassenarbeit interpretieren sie dieses Lied. Und da war, da wurde ich natürlich hellhörig. Weil jetzt, wenn der Lehrer sagt, interpretiere bitte dieses Lied, dann muss es ja auch eine korrekte Lösung geben, weil der Lehrer muss ja sagen, haben sie das jetzt richtig interpretiert oder nicht? Aber will man unsere Schülerinnen und Schüler hier verblöden? Will man die in diesem Land eigentlich verblöden? Was ist denn aus Shakespeare geworden? Nee, aber dann mal den Rilke. Ja. Den Fontane. Vielleicht muss man sich da erst hinarbeiten. Den Goethe. Den Fontane. Warum denn die Stürmer? Warum werden die leidige Stürmer immer mit dem Karren durch den Klassenraum gezogen? Das ist eine gute Frage. Und jetzt habe ich einige Lösungen gefunden zu dieser Interpretation. Allerdings, und da kommen wir zu schulportal.de, kann man da tatsächlich nur drauf zugreifen, wenn man Lehrer ist. Erst dachte ich mir, ja, ja, natürlich bin ich Lehrer, ich klicke das alles an. Aber die wollen auch die Schule wissen, wo du Lehrer bist. Und also ich habe aktuell... Wie funktioniert Schulportal.de? Schulportal.de funktioniert so, du bist Lehrer und musst eine Klassenarbeit vorbereiten. Du bist Lehrer, wenn nicht dein Hochschild... und bringst mir Schmerzen bei. Und wenn du Lehrer bist und musst eine Klassenarbeit vorbereiten, dann kannst du auf Schulportal.de die Klassenarbeit runterladen mit Lösung, dann können die Schüler das schreiben und dann kannst du es korrigieren anhand der Lösung. Mit Lösung. Das heißt, es gibt eine Lösung der Interpretation zu der Schule. Und an die will ich ran. Und deswegen, ich habe aktuell einen Betrugsversuch am Lauf, Betrugsverlaufversuch pending. Ich habe nämlich versucht, mich auf schulportal.de als Lehrer auszugeben. Welche Schule hast du genommen? Das möchte ich nicht sagen, weil ich weiß nicht, welche Behörden hier gerade mithören, ob der Kultusminister hier am Apparello hängt. Deswegen, es kann sein, dass ich nächste Woche die offizielle Lösung für all unsere Fragen geben kann. Andererseits sollte das nicht klappen, wenn ihr Lehrer seid, würdet ihr mir einen grossen Gefallen tun, wenn ihr an die Lösung rankommen könntet und mir die schickt. Das wäre super. Das wäre kostenlos. Nee, das kostet, das kostet, und zwar kostet das Schulportal
Punkte. Nee, steht kostenlos. Das gesamte Angebot von Schulportal.de ist vollständig
kostenfrei, keine versteckten Kosten. Aber hier heißt es, herunterladen für 30 Punkte. Also runterladen kann man die Lösung für 30 Punkte. Ja, da musst du so ein Rätsel, da musst du so Candy Crush oder so Minimitrum. Ja, genau, musst du so Möhren anpflanzen, die du nachts ernten musst. Genau. Also, falls noch irgendein Lehrer von euch da draußen 30 Punkte rumliegen hat, würdet ihr mir einen großen Gefallen tun. Es ist natürlich jetzt gefährlich, weil in dem Moment, in dem wir die Lösung sagen, kann natürlich diese Aufgabe nicht mehr genutzt werden.
Ich glaube ja nicht, dass...
Weil die, es können ja Schüler zuhören...
Nee, Deutschinterpretationsaufgaben, die Lösungen davon sind immer denkbar frei. Das würde mich auch mal interessieren, wie das tatsächlich aussieht, so eine Lösung von so einer Aufgabe. Ja, also selbst so, sagen wir mal, die klassischen, selbst der Erlenkönig wäre ja nicht, obwohl er sich mittlerweile wahrscheinlich tot analysiert ist, wäre dann in der, wäre nicht schablonenhaft.
Das weiß ich eben nicht. Also vielleicht ist es auch wirklich, das bedeutet das und das bedeutet das. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Gewisserweise gibt es solche so Tent-Poles, die immer stimmen müssen, aber darüber hinaus glaube ich, hier führt der Schüler fünf valide argumentierte Beispiele an oder sowas für seine Interpretation, glaube ich, sind ein Punkt. Wenn die Interpretation sie berührt hat, geben sie gerne ein. Geben sie gerne ein Punkt, Pünktchen. Das wird mich nämlich auch interessiert. Bin Hacker, wenn du mein Passwort bist. Das kann man den ganzen Tag auch machen, da kann jeder sein eigenes Lied zu Hause
komponieren. Ich freue mich auf viele Intros,
nach dem Schema die nächsten 20 Folgen.
Das ist übrigens eine... Bin ich ein Roboter,
wenn du der Capture bist.
Es ist eine Aufgabe
für die achte Klasse übrigens.
Also achte Klasse, da ist man
15, 16 Jahre alt. Will man unsere Kinder verblöden?
Die hören doch gern Musik, das kannst du doch anhören im Unterricht. Aber doch nicht die Stürmer. Warum denn nicht? Dann doch wenigstens den Wagner. Wagner! Also wirklich, ich meine es ernst, wenn ihr Lehrer seid, äh Lehrerin, schickt mir gerne die Lösung, dann können wir das gerne interpretieren, weil dann können wir nämlich all diese Fragen endlich lösen.
Und dafür wurden solche Aufgaben gemacht, damit wir mehr über Musik lernen.
Es steckt ja viel drin in so einem Text.
Man muss dazu sagen, so wie ich das recherchiert habe, hat Frau Stürmer diesen Text nicht geschrieben, sondern Alexander K., Eva Kraus, Harald Hanisch und Leopold Zillinger.
Vier Leute. Also ein Writers Room kam hier zusammen, hat sich hingesetzt und hat sich über Monate diesen Text entworfen. Vier Leute sassen an diesem Text. Abschliessend ... Nein, bitte nicht. Abschliessend möchte ich wissen ... Ja, harmonisch löst sich's ja auch. Okay. Aber nicht klar. Ja, ich kann jetzt aus Gema-Gründen nicht hören, ob das die Toniker ist. Ich nehme an, das ist unser Heimatakkord und wir haben ihn alle aufgelöst. Was auch der textlichen Interpretation, die wir gerade versucht haben, entgegensteht. Auch spannend, wenn ihr Musiklehrer seid. Vielleicht gibt es ja auch dafür auf Schulportal.de eine Lösung. Interpretiert mir mal die vier Akkorde, die die ganze Zeit wiederholt werden. Oh ja, okay, jetzt kommt wieder der Wagner, Stefan. Du hast selber mal Pop gelebt, ja? Du hast selber mal mit Pink Isaac Bu versucht, die Popwelt zu revolutionieren. Und jetzt spuckst du auf, Frau Stürmer. Ich habe übrigens eine ganz nette Nachricht bekommen von einem lieben Hörer, der angefangen hat, uns zu hören und dem plötzlich ein Licht aufging und dachte, Moment, mein Name plus Kreis Unna, wo ich geboren bin, da klingelt doch was. und in einer späteren Folge hat er den Bandnamen Binky Sack Bu gehört und dann hat er alle positioniert zusammengesetzt.
Er kannte nämlich die Band und hat mir sogar noch ein Poster geschickt,
dass seine Band mitmacht. und in einer späteren Folge hat er von dem Bandnamen Binky Sag Bu gehört und dann hat er alle positioniert zusammengesetzt.
dass seine Band mit meiner Band auf so einem Bandcontest
oder irgendwie so einem Bandabend gemeinsam aufgetreten ist.
Liebe Grüße gehen in den Kreis Unna.
Voll, voll cool, da sind uns unsere Wege übern.
Ich glaube, da kann man auch noch graben.
Also wenn man mehr über Stefan Tietz herausfindet, kann man da glaube ich graben, da findet man noch viele alte Leute. Hört mal auf zu graben, buddelt lieber, verbuddelt mich wieder. Es wird mir zu viel gegraben, ich gucke euch an Reddit, da wurde zu viel gegraben. Ich habe ein paar Kommentare löschen müssen. Die Leute wissen, was ich meine, hört auf zu graben und verbuddelt wieder.
Schön die Schaufel nehmen, diesen grossen Dreckberg und dann einmal rein, rüber, rein, rüber und dann schön plattklopfen. Da wurden Portale geöffnet, die brauchen wir nicht. Eine Sache noch, um das abzuschliessen, Frau Stürmer, falls Sie jetzt die ganze Zeit mitgehört haben und wirklich Hand am Kopf, wirklich facepalmend, 30 Minuten lang diese Besprechung begleitet. Room. wenn Sie sich rechtfertigen möchten. Zu einem Streitgespräch. Wir laden Sie zu einem Streitgespräch.
Zu einem konfrontativen Streitgespräch laden wir Sie gerne ein im Kaffeezentral in Wien.
Wir räumen das Ganze, da wurde auch mal eine Sendung Literarisches Quartett aufgezeichnet.
Da können wir uns gerne treffen und dann diskutieren wir das aus mit den führenden Literaturwissenschaftlern und Musikwissenschaftlern Deutschlands.
Ja.
Und Österreichs natürlich.
Der Schweiz ist exzlizid nicht.
Nein, der ist exzlizid. Der deutschsprachige Raum ausser der Schweiz. Ausgeschlossen. Explizit raus. Ich möchte den Podcast Servus, Grüzi und Hallo empfehlen. Habe ich dir schon mal empfohlen? Laufen unglaublich lange schon, sind glaube ich auch schon in ihren Zweihundeter-Folgen. Süss. Jedenfalls möchte ich dir empfehlen, macht sehr viel Spaß, drei Zeitjournalisten aus Schweiz, Österreich und Deutschland ordnen die Dinge immer transalpin ein. Es geht immer um die verschiedenen Blickpunkte der verschiedenen Länder und es macht unfassbar viel Spaß. Und man kann bei guter Laune wird das Weltgeschehen eingeordnet von cleveren Leuten, unbedingt die Hörempfehlung. Servus, grüzi und hallo. Wo wir gerade schon bei Nischenthema sind, kannst du uns denn nochmal kurz einordnen in das aktuelle Schachdrama? Ja. Die Leute begieren dann natürlich Infos vom grössten Talent der Geschichte. Ja, irgendwann, da wollte ich auch nochmal Nachtrag, Fussnote, es wurde daraus gemacht, Jahrhunderttalent häufig. Da kann ich ja nur wieder drüber lachen. Nein, der Geschichte, das umfasst mehrere Jahrhunderte. Genau, ein absoluter Schachexperte, Rustam Kasimchanow hat Stefan Tietze das größte Talent der Geschichte genannt. Was machst du mit diesem Talent? Das ist ja auch eine Bürde. Naja, ich musste dann erstmal alle meine Namen ändern, war auf allen Schachportalen, weil ich immer Zuschauer hatte in meinen Partien. Also Leute haben mir über die Schulter geguckt, beziehungsweise meine Partien angeguckt. Habe ich gehasst, fand ich ganz blöd. Man hasst sich eh schon so sehr, wenn man online verliert. Und hat dann überall neue Namen angelegt, beziehungsweise kann nicht mehr auf manchen Portalen spielen und ja, hat da jetzt eine neue Karriere übergekommen und sehr schlecht. Du bist in die Ecke getrieben. Ich bin in die Ecke getrieben worden, vom Pöbel. Der Ruhm treibt dich in die Ecke. Ja, den habe ich mir nicht ausgesucht, der ist mir zugeflogen und da brauche ich ihn nicht. Nee, also das Schachtdrama, es soll ja hier nicht um mich gehen, sondern in dieser Rubrik geht es um, wir können eine Rubrik machen, Schachtdramen der Woche. Und die haben wir schon sehr lange, es gab nur noch nie eins. Und zwar ein Newcomer-Star, 19 Jahre alt, Hans Niemann aus den USA, hat einen deutschen Namen, weil er, glaube ich, deutsche Vorfahren hatte, ist bei einem großen, sein erstes großes Superturnier hat er gespielt. Wirklich eines der großen prestigereichen Turniere im Schachkalender, also sagen wir mal so die US Open, was die für Tennis ist, wäre der Sinkerfield Cup in St. Louis für die Karte. Das ist das große amerikanische Turnier. Und überraschend konnte er in Runde drei dieses Turniers gegen Magnus Carlsen, den amtierenden Weltmeister, der jetzt nicht mehr antritt, aber den besten nach der Elo, auch 300 Elo-Punkte über ihm, bewerteten Spieler gewinnen. Der, muss man davor sagen, die letzten 53 klassischen, klassisch gespielten Over-the-Board-Spielpartien nicht verloren hat.
Der hat 53 Mal, war er ungeschlagen, verliert dann gegen diesen 19-Jährigen. Und am nächsten Tag erschien er nicht. Und ein Tweet ist erschienen, dass er von dem Turnier sich zurückzieht. I'm withdrawing from the tournament. Und hat ein kryptisches YouTube-Video angehangen, wo Jose Mourinho sagt, dass er nicht darüber reden kann, weil er sonst grosse Probleme bekäme. Und die Implikation ist Cheating. An dem gleichen Tag wurde nämlich plötzlich komischerweise auch erst 15 Minuten später angefangen. Die Übertragung ins Internet, also in die Außenwelt, wurde um 15 Minuten verschoben. Man hat immer diese typischen DGT-Boards mit Magneten, wird dann direkt gesehen, der Springer bewegt sich nach F3 und es wird in die Außenwelt in Echtzeit übertragen, damit alle in Echtzeit die Partie verfolgen können. Das wurde um 15 Minuten verschoben, was man nur macht, in den Achtzigern oder sowas, weil man dann Cheating vermutet hatte. Also Hans Niemann hat vielleicht betrogen, hat das irgendwelche Konsequenzen für unser Merch-Design
von Christoph Niemann? Gibt's da... Ja,
grosse Probleme. Sitzen wir jetzt auch mit drin?
Das interessiert mich eigentlich meistens. Ich liebe
das Drama, weil die Implikation
ist ja, dass er entweder Fusssohlen
anhat, die vibrieren, meinetwegen links dreimal,
rechts dreimal, A, C,
drei muss ich bewegen oder sowas,
oder er hat so ein kleines Irrbis in seinem
in seinem Öhrchen. Ja, aber kann man das nicht sehen, wenn er läuft und die Füsse vibrieren? Naja, er ist komisch gelaufen. Er ist wie auf Stelzen gelaufen. Er ist vier Meter hochgesprungen, als er in das Stadion kam. Er ist einmal gegen die Tür gelaufen, weil er zu hoch war. Man weiß es nicht. Aber ich meine, man kann es ja nicht beweisen. Ich glaube, es wird auch weniger darüber gesprochen, als es wirklich Thema ist hinter den Kulissen. Das finde ich wahnsinnig spannend, weil die Implikation ist ja genauso schlimm. Die falsche Implikation ist ja genauso schlimm, wie selber zu betrügen. Das kennt man. Guck mal, er hat 19 Jahre altes Talent. Gut, man muss dazu sagen, er hat auch schon mal nachweislich betrogen. Im Internet aber, bei Online-Turnieren wurde er da gesperrt. Da hatte er zwei Damen, das ist leider erst spät aufgefallen. Das war ungünstig, das tut ihm auch wirklich leid. Er ist drei Schritte mit dem Bauern gegangen, das geht er nicht, aber das ist später aufgefallen. Wurde er gesperrt für neun Monate und er hat nicht Schach gesagt bei der letzten Karte. Also jetzt schwierig, die Schachwelt ist in Aufruhr. Glaubst du, die Schachwelt wird sich davon erholen können? Ich glaube, die Schachwelt macht daraus ein größeres Drama, als es ist, weil die Schachwelt sich gerne selber ein bisschen am bisschen am Leben halten will. Ich finde es wahnsinnig interessant, ich bin gespannt. Ich erwarte jetzt von Magnus Carlson, weil es gibt keinen Beweis für den Cheating-Vorwurf. Hat er was vibrieren hören? Hat Magnus Carlson vibriert und dachte Sekunde? Dem liegt ja was an Gerechtigkeit und so. Ich finde es so problematisch und super heuchlerisch, dass er dann dieses Video postet, wenn ich darüber rede, bin ich in großen Schwierigkeiten, was super direkt impliziert, was er vermutet. Also und dann sozusagen, ich kann nicht sagen, weil das würde Leute oder das würde irgendwie einen Vorwurf verlautbaren, der vielleicht nicht haltbar ist, ja dann mach es nicht. Also du hast ja super klar gesagt, der Mann cheatet und jetzt muss ein Beweis kommen, andernfalls bist du dabei, die Karriere von dem 19-Jährigen zu zerstören, der vielleicht einfach nur gut gespielt hat gegen dich. Aber nur um das zu verstehen, der hätte dann einen Schuh angehabt, der für ihn Schach spielt. Es gibt verschiedene Theorien. Analplug, Schuhe. Ein vibrierender Analplug. Ein Koordinaten, ein morsender Analplug. der ihm quasi die Botschaft aus dem Darm ihm den richtigen Zug kompliziert.
Seine Kontaktlinse scannt das Brett und an sein Anal-Plug ist ein Engine angeschlossen.
Aber warum spielt sein Anal-Plug besser als er Schach?
Ich glaube, der Anal-Plug wäre verbunden mit einem Menschen draußen, der einen Schachcomputer am Laufen hat. Das ist ja super einfach. Selbst ich könnte ihm ja die Züge geben. Das Problem ist ja auch, da hilft es vielleicht, wenn man Schach so gut versteht wie ich als begeisterter Spieler der Geschichte. Es reichen ja zwei Züge. Es reichen ja kritische Momente. Der spielt ja super Schach, das ist ja keine Frage, dass er ein sehr guter Schachspieler ist,
ein Großmeister. Wenn das von dir kommt,
glaube ich, würde ihn das auch aufmachen.
Wir würden ihn vielleicht freuen, aber vielleicht würde er ihm den Clip schicken.
Er spielt sehr gut,
deswegen, ich glaube, ihm reichen drei, vier
kritische Momente in der Partie gegen Magnus
und der gewinnt.
Drei, vier Momente, die du als Mensch
normalerweise nicht siehst, aber ein Computer,
für den ist das der beste Zug. Ich war ja oft in Italien in so Spielhallen, wo es diese Automaten gibt, wo so ganz viele Münzen sind, die so nach vorne geschoben werden. Genau. Und dann sind wahnsinnig viele Münzen und denkst dir, Alter, wenn ich da nur eine richtige Münze werfe. Und da war es so, und das ist vielleicht als Tipp, wenn du da versucht hast, den Automaten zu schütteln, dann ging automatisch die Klappe zu und ja, Cheating-Verdacht. Könnte man sowas nicht auch in so einen Schachstuhl einbauen, dass wenn der vibriert, der sagt, Vorsicht, hier vibriert was? Oder meinst du, dass wenn der Anal-Plug vibriert, das gar nicht am Stuhl ankommt? Ich glaube ... Da brauchst du natürlich die passende Muskulatur. Ich glaube, Magnus Carlsen hat das Vibrieren gehört, slash gefühlt, sonst hätte er nicht diese Vorwürfe im Internet verlautbaren lassen. Wirklich. Aber er hat in dem Moment nicht gesagt, Entschuldigung, vibrieren Sie? Nein. Ich habe es doch gerade im Vibrieren gespürt und gehört. Nein. Nein. Nein. Es fühlt sich auch wahnsinnig gut an wahrscheinlich. Er ist einfach nur gesteuert von so einem ... Ja, das ist das Problem. Selbst wenn du verlierst, du darfst nicht zeigen, dass es dir gerade richtig gut ist. Selbst wenn du verlierst, geht es dir richtig gut. Ich gehe jetzt erst mal schön rennen Kaffee.
Ja, also ich halte euch da auf dem Laufenden.
Bislang gibt es nichts Neues.
Er wurde jetzt wieder gesperrt von Chess.com.
Hast du noch Kontakt mit ihm oder hast du es abgebrochen komplett?
Ich hatte noch nie Kontakt zu einem Cheater.
Uh, okay.
Also Stefan Tietze hat sich klar positioniert,
das wird natürlich in der Schachpresse auch aufgenommen.
Wir warten natürlich immer noch, dass das Rösselsprung covert mit Stefan Tietze. Jetzt spricht er, Stefan Tietze hat sich klar positioniert, das wird natürlich in der Schachpresse auch aufgenommen. Wir warten natürlich immer noch, dass das Rösselsprung covert mit Stefan Tietze. Jetzt spricht er, Stefan Tietze spricht. Stefan bricht das Schweigen. Also haltet da wirklich die Augen offen am Bahnhofskiosk, ob ihr da vielleicht die neue Ausgabe noch greifen könnt. Haltet die Augen offen, beziehungsweise sucht auch aktiv nach dem oft nach hinten gerutschten Schachmagazin. Wir distanzieren uns als Podcast natürlich von Betrug jeder Art, außer Schuhportal, aber das ist ja was anderes. Das ist ja wirklich Bildung, das ist ja nur für, damit ihr alles so. Aber ansonsten, bitte, bitte, bitte schaut mal, dass ihr zumindest in der Woche nicht betrückt. Das war jetzt ein Kompromiss. Sagen wir mal, dass wir wirklich die kommende Woche, dass ihr nicht eine Woche nicht betrügt. Und ich glaube, ihr werdet merken, es geht euch besser. Ja. Sorry, dass es ein bisschen so eine Christina-Stürmer-lastige Show geworden ist, aber das musste jetzt mal raus. Das musste mal besprochen werden. Und das wisst ihr auch, das wisst ihr auch selbst. Ja. Es macht vielleicht keinen Spaß. Wir fühlen uns jetzt alle besser. Aber wir fühlen uns jetzt besser. Wir haben es geschafft heute schon.
Uns würde natürlich auch sehr interessieren,
wie ihr das Ganze interpretiert.
Vielleicht schreibt ihr ein neues Lied.
Ach so.
Ne, lass uns mal weg jetzt von Stürmer.
Hin zu neuen Welten.
Mach mal wieder ein geiles Intro für uns.
So wie heute?
Zehn Ton Obsidian.
Richtig gut, vielen Dank dafür, haut rein, wir heben ab, mal eine gute schöne Woche.
Ciao, ciao.
It's a worst burr production. Du suchst den Vibe? Abseits vom Standard? Willkommen im Ruhrgebiet. Echt statt inszeniert. Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt. Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Heide. Klingt anders? Ist es auch. Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt. Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet.